[Applause]
and I love Halloween - like it's right
up there with Christmas I love dressing
up the kids
I literally have walked through haunted
houses that I do like I don't do that
for the neighborhood house I literally I
was through in women and children out of
the way I was like I don't like to be I
married the wrong person he lets just
scare the crap out of everyone and I
like if you do it there's no cuddles for
you for a week I hate being scared I
can't cut you haunted houses no they're
like you can pick your level though you
can go like okay I won and maybe I like
it creepy like scary Candyland we have
grow onto something I kind of love it
the great way I know you're gonna do
this um so here's the big news also as
well your Vegas residency at Planet
Hollywood was just extended what do you
love cuz everybody's doing a Vegas here
so what do you love about it the
experience you have to come bring a fun
group of people because I love feeding
off the energy but it's it's it's a
great it's a great environment it's a
great place to be expressive and
creative and you know I feel at home
most when I'm on stage and it's a five
sensory experience so you can smell
taste it's like you can you know the
ride that what is it like Jasmine yeah
yeah actually it's so funny you say we
we're I know I also have a snow Club
idea I want to do a Christmas show in
Vegas I want to all be a snow globe
great my whole world so we're still some
oh my god you should comment we should
sing a song in Vegas okay
[Applause]
do you have any crazy cousin thing my
husband I tried to because we have four
kids and it's like fun to just be an
adult like a fun adult again and have
like a night with your ladies or your
friends whatever and so do you have any
wild fun nights and Vegas all the good
ones I'm I'm proud to have minimal
memory abut I like to go out with my
like crew like my dancers are so fun to
go out with my god or not you're not
you're big cuz you're like yeah you look
great no I'm not gonna join you know I
kind of like let them edit but they're
entertaining they're just like my bands
like that yeah my fans like that
they're all cool I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this